لقضاء وقت اطول تستهدف خوارزميات تيك توك
مرتديها بمنشورات معينه بعد تحديد المحتوى
المثير بالنسبه لهم لكن ليس هذا فقط
ادخلوا الصقرير الى ان المنصه تعزز مقاطع
تروج لايذاء الذات واضطرابات الاكل
للمراهقين المعرضين للخطر التقرير اعتمد
على تجربه انشاء فيها باحثون في مركز
مكافحه الكراهيه الرقميه غير الربحي
حسابات للشخصيات مراهقين خياليه في
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وكندا
واستراليا لتبدا منصه خلال دقائق باظهار
مقاطع حول فقدان الوزن واذا النفس وصور
لانواع اجسام المثاليه ومناقشات حول
الانتحار وعند تجربه اسماء تتضمن عبارات
تشير الى مواضيع معينه مثل فقدان الوزن
يظهر محتوى اكثر ضررارا هذه النتائج جعلت
القائمين على الدراسه يعتبرون ان
خوارزميات تيك توك
حرفيا اخطر الرسائل الممكنه للشباب اما
تيك توك نفسها عارضت نتائج الدراسه معتبره
ان الباحثين لم يستخدموا النظام الاساسي
مثل المستخدمين العاديين ما اظهر نتائج
منحرفه وان نسمح حساب المستخدم لا يؤثر
على نوع المحتوى الذي يستقبله المستخدمه
ومن جهه اخرى اكدت منظمه فيرب بلاي وهي
منظمه غير ربحيه تدعم حمايه اكبر على
الانترنت للاطفال ان كل هذه الاضرار ترتبط
اساسا بنموذج العمل وان وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في حد ذاتها ليست المقصوده ما
يثير تساؤلات اكبر حول مدى خطوره هذه
منصات على حياه الاطفال والمراهقين الذين
يقضون اوقات طويله امامها